31 women a day die in this country from
breast cancer every day I mean that's
actually a shocking figure still isn't
it in 2022 people are much less scared
of breast cancer now I mean the drop in
mortality rates is very significant
obviously the messaging that's been out
for the last 30 years remembering that
before
campaigns like this started before the
pink ribbon had been invented before
there was a breast cancer awareness
month nobody knew anything about breast
cancer we certainly wouldn't have been
sitting here talking about breast cancer
for National Television
um magazines didn't talk about it
families didn't talk about it and I know
from first-hand experience of my
grandmother who was diagnosed before
this campaign started that she didn't
talk about it either and we didn't know
anything about her disease we didn't
know anything about her treatment and in
fact we now know that doctors and
research scientists also knew a lot less
if you are diagnosed early there is
still a 90 chance that you will recover
from your diagnosis after treatment I
think there is room for Hope young women
can get breast cancer and young women
can die of breast cancer because eight
out of ten women don't regularly check
their breasts and some women admit that
they never do what would you say to
those women unfortunately that is a
misconception and I have met countless
young women in their 20s or earlier who
have been diagnosed with breast cancer
and most of them have found their lumps
themselves and many of them found them
inadvertently
soaping in the shower trying to drop a
bra that was sticking on something it
can happen and it that you know that
that is why young women do need to
self-check we do know that some groups
are much worse at looking out for breast
cancer and if they find something going
to the doctor particularly black women
particularly South Asian women
there's a stigma maybe in those
communities how on Earth do you get
around that
hearing their stories reminding me very
much
of how it was when my grandmother was
diagnosed in the early 90s where she
didn't want to tell anyone she thought
she'd be judged she didn't want pity
when people knew nothing
they wanted it to be brushed aside and
that's very much what
um two of our ambassadors have said to
us from the South Asian community and
from the black community and our young
Ambassador is also very interesting on
the subject she actually said that the
peers and the groups that she's talking
to they are actually fine talking about
breast cancer they feel they had been
told in school or by friends or by
family members or in magazines or shows
like this to self-check
but most of them still thought it
wouldn't happen to them because they
were young or because they were kind of
flat chested or various other things
what would you say to those women who
are thinking if I go to that screening
I'll have to spend
X number of pounds on my bus fare and if
I don't go I'll save that money and I
can spend it on something else I mean
it's a big problem you know in in this
day and age particularly at the moment
it's a big problem how do you how do you
get around that and make people go to
their screenings when you can't make
people do anything can you I I I suppose
it's just through education but
interestingly enough
um
uh there's an extra 15 million dollar
one five fifteen million dollars being
um given to the Breast Cancer Research
Foundation over the next couple of years
to expressly deal with the disparities a
black woman is 40 more likely to die of
breast cancer than a white woman
and there's different reasons for that
you design bikinis you model bikinis
um you have great body confidence
clearly um do you think body confidence
is an issue with people not checking
people not going to their screenings
it's just not something they would do
stand naked or stand topless in front of
a mirror or stand topless in front of a
strange nurse I think In some cultures
yes it is I think it is to be topless in
front of a nurse sometimes as women we
put ourselves right at the bottom of the
list of things to do you know we're
caretakers we take care of everybody
else the house the kids everything
school bags School runs we're doing
everything and very often we do come
last but unfortunately I think that's
something that we do need to try to talk
about because you know caretakers can't
really take care of people if they're
not there
do you think we'll ever be in a world
where we won't need pink October because
there'll be a cure and people won't die
from breast cancer I do believe there
will be a world where women do not where
anyone man or woman does not die of
breast cancer I truly believe that and
I've spoken to some of the best research
scientists in the world and they said
yes there will be a time and all we need
is more money and more research is it
far away do you think well that I can't
really say but um what I can say is that
every year we're told something very
encouraging which has been discovered in
research
um
I mean treatments are so much better now
than they were 30 years ago I mean it's
so much better and the diagnosis they
come up with unbelievable information
all the time
so yes I don't know a timeline but I
hope it's in my lifetime